yo this is high definition of the
unconventional Kings and this is lowkey
The Wizard of the unconventional Kings
and we done made it all the way to the
boot Lake cev podcast let me WAP for
you Killer Mike and
LP run a je
[__] we look up to y'all man high
def these boys going need their Jesus up
believe in this unconventional King
decree and the end of this evilness are
you seeing this [__] are you believing
this [__] tell me why these tough ass
refers H and flee from this [__] must be
the degree of the grit seeing that we
with this [__] don't even need a full
clip to saw you [__] in has spit it
fast sing it slow get the cast that's
your ho it could be the easiest game and
it the M it Li low hacking the backpack
and spe traing rest with tabulous notes
repping for positive growth not into
destroying enough folks build them up
and then go forward trying to acquire
the most then live fast and that's slow
hit the gas but not low cuz we pass up
my v and we just catching our Buzz we
what it's going to be and we don't give
a [__] what it was respect to blood an
cu the king they came before us told us
to stay off of drugs where the they
wasn't the was you ain't going to need
no fluid to light me up don't Hy me up
my people will tell you that I'm round
tight don't try me son I try to stay so
far from violence but you know how it
goes when a couple of guys on deep and a
seat blows and a de go to the back of
the Thro all because the peace go when
people can't sh ego there ain't no
reason we can't live together as people
make marijana legal we'll smoke up then
VI out be peaceful but we know Geeks
when in evil and corporations GRE so my
skin col legal to liso you think you can
act like them won't you try it out let's
see how long them tough ass words be
coming out your mouth slide on the track
like the street sweeper we beat beaters
popping like the boogalo style load up
the heat Seekers get nobody told all
these chumps we the chief speakers high
definition and lowkey we a Le
fig again salute run the Jews man we
want to come and tour with you
[__] if you see this but I'm a
Midwest Chopper
though so
so R you made it about the Trap leave
without looking back no I more than that
no time to be falling back all our folks
can run a rap to help to the front of
that it no matter if white or black when
they go no coming back so it's time that
we SC that everything that they do can
be a of the future that creates our own
sh that R own sh build up each other of
young men living long enough to do grown
[__] got to own this can control this
pick up the bone man act like Ro man
leave alone on wax I ain't saying don't
go in but when it's all of a man
everybody got to live everybody got kids
it's why we live in the world without n
no PO Smoke No Big Y really rocking with
that King B [__] killing the knowing
that he s some ra sh but some chops when
they already braing and if we the [__]
what the [__] would you call
it we're so grateful the bootleg C man
bringing us out here we only been at
this for a couple of years y'all
but man low key
look set your should up for the
coronation it's a little something about
these Kings you facing we don't give a
damn about the food you tasting the cars
you driving of the money you wasting we
cool with that I mean we do that too
same time making better music than you
up in the Kingdom making tunes for them
on that [__] ain't going to last [__]
the big guns and Y don't even know it
man that's what we come in listen to me
when I tell you cat so we all can it's
time to we fall and only way that we all
win is take out of these coffins all
gasing all of the all ain't no time for
no balling half the Callin got a Wonder
for all the KC the a Minnesota the new D
the C the people are
falling UNC convincing no Kings
[__] hey you just watched
another freestyle brought to you by the
good Folks at LRG goddamn it shout out
to LRG all right go use the promo code
bootleg right now on their website
l-r-g.com
say 40% off at checkout 40% off at
checkout use that promo code and we got
another freestyle coming ASAP